- Since it's design week,
we wanted to put our
design skills to the test
in a little something we're
calling "Design Derby".
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
- But gosh, I would
love a worthy adversary
who's as design obsessed as me. (gasps)
I'm so lucky.
(Ross laughing)
I know of someone.
It is comedian, actor, author,
woman extraordinaire, host
of "The Circle" on Netflix,
and design darling and our
dear friend, Michelle Buteau!
- Oh, my gosh!
(audience cheering)
Oh, my gosh, it's me!
(Ross laughing)
- And, of course, we have the best host
to take us through it all,
it's Rossi Ross Matthews.
- That's right!
This is a very serious game,
and here's how it's gonna go down, ladies.
I'm gonna ask you a series
of design related questions.
You'll each write your answer
on your little
whiteboard right there.
- Okay. Okay.
- And whoever gets the most right
wins a prize for their
half of the audience.
- Ooh.
- Hey!
- Whoa!
- Which half am I?
Which half is Michelle?
- All right, Drew.
You're playing for that
half of the audience
over there.
- Hi, guys!
(audience cheering)
- And Michelle, this is your half
of the audience right here.
You're playing for them!
- Give it up! Give it up!
(audience cheering)
- Okay.
- What are we winning?
I'm so excited.
- I'll tell you
at the end.
- Okay.
- Oh, god, there's stakes.
- There are stakes.
All right, let's go.
Question number one. Take a look at this.
This is an Arco floor lamp.
- Oh, yeah.
- It became popular when it appeared
in the 1971 Sean Connery
film, "Diamonds Are Forever".
It has a very heavy, marble base.
How much does this lamp cost?
- Oh!
- Write it down on your board.
Whoever gets closest without
going over gets the point.
Like "Price Is Right" style.
Michelle, why don't you-
- Why am I nervous?
- Why don't you reveal-
- Because you have
a whole group of people
- I know,
you're counting on me.
- You're playing for.
- I don't wanna let you down.
(audience cheering)
- All right.
- Okay.
- Let's take a look
at how much you think
that Arco floor lamp is.
- I mean, it depends
where you get it from,
but I'm gonna say around here.
- 3,200 to 3,300, okay.
All right. Good guess.
Drew, 2,500.
Okay the actual price for
that Arco lamp is $3,695.
- Oh!
- Michelle!
- Oh, I got it!
- Yeah!
- [Michelle] Oh, my goodness!
- Michelle got that right,
which means this side of the audience,
you have one point.
- Whoo!
- Drew's still trying to catch up.
(audience cheering)
- [Michelle] We did
it. I'm so proud of us.
- All right, question number
two is a drawing challenge.
- Oh.
- Oh, no.
- Yeah, you're gonna draw.
You have 20 seconds to draw
the famous Eames Lounge Chair.
This is an iconic chair
that popped up in TV shows
like "Frasier", "House",
and every gay in Palm Springs has it.
(Ross chuckling)
(audience laughing)
- With the, I'm not,
I didn't go to art school.
- Who's got the best version?
- This is not good.
A drawing challenge?
- Okay.
And time is up. Time is up.
Reveal. Drew, reveal yours.
Well done, actually.
Michelle, let's take a look at yours.
- I mean, you know.
(Michelle laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Well, let's see how close they got.
This is what the actual
Eames chair looks like.
- Yes.
- Okay.
So you know what?
I actually think you both get a point,
because you both did really well.
- Oh, okay, Oprah.
You get a point, you get a point.
- Okay.
- My team is mad.
My team is mad.
I see hands up there not liking it.
- Oh, yeah.
- Shots fired.
- All right.
- Pew, pew, pew.
- Listen, everyone calm down.
The game is two for
Michelle, one for Drew,
but anyone can still win this.
Let's go to question
number three.
- All right. Oh, gosh.
- All right, a hugely popular
furniture and design store
gives all their furniture
Swedish inspired names.
We know them, right?
Their fjallbo shelves are a go-to
if you're going for a rustic vibe.
How do you spell fjallbo?
It's Swedish.
- More like bachelor vibe
that has to use his mom's
credit card, but that's okay.
We'll say rustic.
(Ross laughing)
- Mm-hmm.
- I don't know.
- Oh, god.
- Oh, god,
I didn't get the bout.
- Okay, Drew, hold yours up.
- Ooh.
- Fil-a-boug. Okay.
That is a really phonetical guess.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
Okay. Michelle, what is your spelling?
- Okay, I got very nervous,
so it's not this, but this.
I don't know.
- Wow, you have umlauts!
- Oh, yes.
- Oh, you know,
those are those two little dots.
I will say, there are
umlauts in the real spelling.
Fjallbo is spelled F-J-A
- Oh!
- umlauts, L-L-B-O,
which means neither one of you
were close, really.
- No.
- Wait, isn't there a J, you said?
- There's a J.
- That's the J.
- [Drew] Michelle gets this one.
- You wanna give her a point?
- Yeah. I should have gotten the chair,
but she-
- Aw, thank you!
(audience cheering)
You guys, we got another point!
Get into it!
- All right.
- That hurt so much.
- Okay, Drew, this is it.
You're gonna win on this one.
- Go!
- Okay, question number four.
It's a picture scramble.
Look behind you.
- Oh!
- Who is this popular interior designer
who was once a regular guest
on "The Oprah Winfrey Show"?
- Oh, come on!
- He's also
appeared on this show.
Turn around. Nate Berkus!
Yes, Nate Berkus!
- Love him!
- Did I get that one?
- You get that one?
- Yes, you did!
- You get that one.
- I'm playing for that side, right there!
- So cool.
- Okay.
(audience cheering)
- Final question
(Michelle laughing)
is worth three points,
so it's anybody's game.
Okay?
- Yeah!
- Oh, good!
- All right.
This is a physical challenge.
- No, I didn't stretch!
- Next to you,
is a pile of rug samples.
- Oh, okay.
- When I say go, I want
you to flip through
and find the rug that best
resembles chevron print.
Okay? Count me in.
Three, two, one, go!
- Three, two, one.
(audience cheering)
- There is no gosh darn chevron in here!
- Where's the chevron? Is this it?
- That's it! That's it!
She found it!
- I put it on the floor.
(audience cheering)
- Which means the winner
of "The Drew Barrymore Show
Design Derby" is Michelle!
- I've got something
in my eyes, right now.
It's on my face.
It's not being nice.
- Michelle,
you are a worthy adversary
in that plaid suit.
You are giving it.
- Thank you, so much.
- And guess what your
audience is getting it
because they're winning a
prize, but you know what?
You're all gonna go home with a prize.
(audience cheering)
(Michelle cheering)
It's a $100 gift card to Costa Farms.
You can freshen up your
living space with some plants.
Did you know plants relieve stress?
That is science,
and you're all getting a $100 gift card.
- Get some plants!
- All right! So nice!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, Costa Farms, for that.
(bright music)